your bag listen we got a an amazing show
for you tonight
Andy I got I'm sorry Andy see if you can
stay off your phone long enough to check
out the show not seriously okay I'm
sorry I just I was in the middle of
something I I got a big shoot coming up
you know you got a big photo shoot huh
yeah big photo shoot for goofing off on
the job magazine sick burn
is that happening right look make fun of
me all you want I don't need this job
anyway I already make a good living as a
successful male model well no no offense
any I just I find it a little hard to
believe that you're a male model you
know yeah that's why I always carry this
card I'm sorry it says that says blurry
boys action models I have no idea what
that is
yeah see that's why I also carry this
video play it modeling is man's work and
being a blurry boy takes looks pizzazz
and the ability to look busy while the
camera focuses on a more handsome model
in style and out of focus on the scene
but never see perfect for models in the
witness protection program
I could have signed with anyone Fuzzy's
fellows soft-focus studs the cataract
pack but blurry boys was the only
modeling agency that had free juice
boxes
you can't see my face but I don't mind
because I got a couple warrants out on
me before I was just some guy living in
a storage container now I'm a male model
living in a storage container
my models can lose a thumb get burning
the Grizz fire and still work blurry boy
number one sorry for a free brochure so
all you nontraditional-looking men out
there who aspire to be male models
I hope our work inspires you and never
forget hey I got a mention this is
incredible
coming up James Comey is gonna be here
[Applause]
you